I just had somebody ask me the most phenomenal question,
and I wanted to bring it to y'all
because I would love to know what your answer is.
Someone just asked me if I could go back in time,
if I would get married again,
and my answer is an immediate yes.
If I could go back in time and married my husband again,
I would marry him a thousand times over.
But we've had the discourse on this app of,
if something happened to your husband,
would you get married again?
This is not that question.
I wanna know, if you could go back in time,
would you get married again?
Because the person who asked me said that they would not.
But hindsight is 20 20 in a lot of cases.
And I am just interested for those who say if they could go back,
they wouldn't get married,
what is stopping you from leaving now